all right so speaking five languages
and giving another causal inference talk
which is incredibly popular
popular these days there's a reason we
schedule two of them because
it's a hot topic please welcome camilla
but this is the last talk of the day so
hopefully i'll make this talk
as uh relevant and fun as possible so
my name is camilla and i'm a data
scientist at code academy
and today we'll go over industry
applications of
causal inference methods um so
specifically these are causal inference
methods
um that are very prevalent in
observational studies and that i've
leveraged in my previous experience
uh when a b testing was just not on the
table um
we have a very very packed agenda that i
will try to make this
as as exciting as possible so i'll give
a very high level overview
why well in general companies tech
companies do love a b testing i won't
spend too much time since i know in the
past
um talks there has been uh there has
been a good amount of
information on this topic i'll give
example of a
of an a b test that we ran at code
academy um
followed by some limitations of a b
testing so limitations and constraints
and that's really going to be the
foundation of the second half
of our second half of our talk and the
most important part of our talk which
uh i call quasi experimental methods for
the win
and so specifically we'll be designing
an experiment for a safety product
together
i'll explain later what a safety product
is um we'll be applying so the
quasi-experimental method that we'll be
focusing on
is differences in differences so we'll
apply that in our quasi-experiment
and we'll compute the average treatment
effect in r
uh if we have enough time we'll discuss
an additional method uh surprise
additional method
um my team told me to end at diffendiff
but
it's it's it's a very it's a great
method so if you have time i'll go over
it
um so cool a gold standard for
experimentation a b testing
so at a very high level um an a b test
is just a perfectly
randomized and controlled experiment
used to
infer uh causality and so essentially
with your treatment
um you can estimate the causal impact on
your outcome
and it's a very iterative and
straightforward technique
and it's used to measure the
effectiveness of product changes
and feature launches um you know at a
very simplistic level
let's say you have two different designs
you don't necessarily
know how it's going to impact your user
behavior you have a very clear
hypothesis
um and your your your variant is pretty
straightforward
um and you have the infrastructure to go
ahead and randomize um then you can just
use a difference in means
uh hypo difference and means test uh to
measure that incremental lift
and so an example of that um is a
okay is what we ran recently at code
academy so what you see here is your
learning environment so
for those of you who have uh never
logged in or
gone on code academy i highly recommend
it it's an excellent learning platform
um our developers really like curate
this content with care
um and so here what you'll see is that
i'm i'm learning
i'm learning javascript and in the lower
bottom the bottom right uh
part of the of the screen you see this
get help
and really um get help is just like if
you were to click it
it would bring you to a bunch of like
supplemental
uh material on um cheat sheets
discussion forums
it really is supposed to help all of the
learning it's just additional learning
content
um but after running a bunch of user
interviews we saw that actually users uh
thought that it was a link to our
customer support
so they were not necessarily clicking on
it and not unfortunately not getting
access to this great learning material
so what we decided to do with a fellow
engineer is well let's just go run a
simple
a b test right so it's a very simple
front-end change
and essentially what you're doing is
you're changing your
um essentially you're introducing you're
changing your treatment and your variant
here
is going from get help to get unstuck
and your
your hypothesis is that you're
essentially going to be able to see an
increase
in in click-through rate and so that's
what we were able to develop
um that's as simple as it gets in terms
of a b testing
if you are able to be in an environment
where you can replicate this type of
test
it's a great way to infer causality um
unfortunately
it's not very often the case and so
we'll go over
um the limitations and constraints and
so first and foremost a lot of the times
randomization is not possible
so either uh because you don't have the
engineering and infrastructure
complexities or capabilities um and
another times you could be in a very
let's say highly regulated industry
right let's say you are in finance
you're in transportation right share you
have a little bit like as a data
scientist like less flexibility on
who you can assign to treatment and
control and sometimes you're you can't
even randomize right so you need to be
able to leverage additional tools
second of all um really a b testing
ignores a lot of these confounding
factors or like
noise that happens prior to your
intervention so a lot of pre-existing
differences um such as like selection or
participation bias
wouldn't necessarily be taken into
account uh when looking at your outcome
or your differences
in outcome and so essentially what you
need to be able to do is to
kind of leverage uh here what we're
going to call
quasi-experimental methods um to be able
to estimate your treatment effect
and that's really what we're going to be
doing in this in this big meat of the
talk
so a few caveats here um i will really
be focusing on
uh industry applications right this is
not a theoretical course i will not be
reproving any of these methods but i
want to go over some examples um that i
think are very valuable
um in a different industry right um so
a little bit of background about me
prior to code academy
i was data scientist at uber um on the
safety team
and so as you can imagine like uber is
just like way more of a regulated space
um regulated i'm saying i'm using this
term very loosely but
essentially like you're building
products and models um
that are directly impacting people's
lives right writers
drivers couriers so you need to be very
sensitive on what you decide
to launch on top of that being on the
safety team
you're really just trying to like build
out products that ensure the safety
of your of your users um but the
additional constraint here
is that you have to take into
consideration marketplace effects
uh so essentially like yes it's great
you want to keep your user safety and
that is our p0 but
um a lot of the times you need to think
about things like eta
pricing trips etc so you're in a way
more
a constrained and complex environment
and so
uh what i wanted to do is uh for us
together to go over an experiment
um that leverages some of these
techniques
so before we get started i want to go
over this post
uh from the right share guy so the
rideshare guy is a very famous blogger
in the ride sharing industry
um he essentially writes about like
products feature launches
policies um that could potentially you
know affect your writer your drivers and
your
your couriers and so essentially he
claims so he writes
back in 2016 um can dashcams
prevent bad passenger behavior and a big
giveaway so dash cams especially if
you're if you're in new york
um drivers have them all over their cars
like in their windshields
and essentially all it is it has these
video recording capabilities
in the sense that um if something were
to happen between like
writer driver two writers uh even like
in case of a traffic violation or
if god forbid they were in an accident
or whatnot they would be able to record
it
send it over to customer support and
just like speed up the entire operation
of like resolving that dispute um and so
what's really interesting here is that
like this is this is a hypothetical
experiment that we would be able to run
right
essentially what we would want to be
able to see if this is you know
if this claim is actual is actually
factual or not is
let's measure the impact of dash cams on
driver safety
great and so you would think well okay
this is actually pretty could be
potentially a pretty classic experiment
right
where you have um you know let's why
don't we just like
give dash cams to 50 of our drivers no
gap dash cams to other 50
of our drivers and just let the
experiment run and see after a certain a
lot of
amount of time how our incident rate uh
would progress so here
our success metric or outcome is our
incident rate which is just your number
of incidents divided by your number of
trips multiple reasons we can't do that
which i've
talked about briefly in like the
limitations section of a b testing which
is
well first of all we can't perfectly
randomize right um if this is a
countrywide program
um there are specifically uh
some uh states that just don't allow for
recording right so
we have less of a sample um to be able
to split for our treatment and control
um and also it's just like there are
there are some heavy legal
considerations here right like if we're
saying that this is positive this is a
beneficial thing
to our driver and that these
ride-sharing companies are willing to
finance
dash cam we can't just go ahead and say
well yeah some drivers are just not
going to be able to get this
because well it's part of an experiment
so here we essentially need to be able
to leverage
an additional technique which in this
case is a difference in difference
method
and at a very high level very
simplistically um cat
calls it like a strategic uh subtraction
and that's all it is
it's a pre post with some very strict
assumptions
essentially what you're doing is you're
looking at your difference
in your outcome after your intro after
your intervention
and you're subtracting that to the
difference in incident rate
prior to your intervention so you're
just computing you're just doing two
differences
you could do multiple in reality but
really here in this case you're just
doing
two um differences and essentially what
you get
is that that incremental effect which
would that be your treatment effect
but the biggest thing um the biggest
thing that's specific
to a uh to a different diff is your
parallel trends assumption
and all that's saying is that without
the without the dash cam's program
average driver incident rate would have
followed the same evolution as the
control group right
um if we if this parallel trends
assumption
was violated we would not be able to um
compute that incremental
effect and so visually this is what it
looks like
right um so this is an excellent post uh
from columbia
um that their public policy uh
department
uh wrote about so i highly recommend
taking a look but essentially what
you'll see here
is that prior to the intervention
you observe a constant difference in
outcome right and this is actually
something that you're also
observing uh in your post intervention
um by creating this unobserved uh
counter factual
and so all it's doing is that after the
intervention you're computing this
intervention effect now there are two
additional assumptions that have to be
held in order to
in order to apply a different diff so we
talked about parallel trends
um but exchangeability which is just
saying that in the absence of treatment
um the unobserved differences between
treatment and control groups are the
same over time
and your stable unit treatment value
assumption which is a lot of words to
say
no interference right the units do not
interfere with each other
and the treatment applied to one unit
does not uh affect the outcome of
another unit
so if we go back to this dashcam's
examples it's really saying that the
fact that the driver
did purchase a dashcam it has no effect
on the incident rate
of another driver right these are all
independent events
and so once you are able to apply all of
these assumptions
then you can just this essentially
removes a lot of the about the biases
between
uh treatment and control and your post
intervention
so great so intuitively this makes a lot
of sense um so different dips right this
is a field that
this was a method that was originated in
econometrics
for like large scale policy evaluations
so it's very it's very easy to
understand
um and on top of that it's even easier
to compute
and so uh
essentially what you're doing is just
you're you're running a regression
right you're running a regression to be
able to estimate
this beta 3 which is your difference in
difference estimator
um and so i can go over very quickly
what all these uh coefficients are um
but it's just a generalized linear model
right your beta naught is your intercept
your beta one measures the time change
comment your treatment control
your beta two measures the difference
between treatment and control before the
intervention
um your beta three that's the estimator
that's what we're gonna get estimates
for
measures the effect of the intervention
and your beta 4 controls for covariates
common to both treatment control
and then you have your error term and so
now how would we compute this in r
very simply you can compute this in in
two lines of code um
i mean i i'm completely exaggerating but
really that's all you're doing right
you're regressing your outcome variable
on this interaction term between your
cohorts or your treatment and your post
interaction
the one thing that i will say before we
go over these uh go over these
uh results is that the way that you
model your data is very very critical
and being able to get um estimates for
your different
for your differences and differences
essentially you need to mutate it
and get um so your uh
cohort indicator so you need to be able
to know
which of your users or drivers or
whatever were part of your treatment and
control
prior and post your intervention um but
you also need a time indicator you need
to be able to say what happened before
and what what happened after and so once
you run your regression
so okay full honesty right now i just
run it as a linear model
um an incident rate that's a count right
so it would actually be a glm
where you would have to specify your
your family to be your you know your
personal distribution
um but once you have that you can then
go ahead and look at your coefficients
right
and the one that we're really interested
in estimating is this last one
which is the interaction between your
treatment and your post
and so here what we're seeing is that
indeed um your estimate
is um is negative 3.2 times whatever
it's not important
um but it's significant at a level of
0.05 and all that's saying is that
indeed um your intervention so your
introduction introduction of dash cams
did lead uh to a decreased incident rate
uh
incident rate which is very much in line
with our initial hypothesis
so that's great um so that that is your
different diff essentially like we it's
very highly highly intuitive
um very easy to compute in r um and used
a lot in large scale
um evaluations i think i will i will go
over this one additional method just
because we have two minutes left and so
um essentially the last one that i will
go over is your um
synthetic control and the only reason
that i want to go over it is because
well first of all it's very very much
used in marketplaces
um but also um it's used in rare events
which is really what we're trying to
model here we're trying to understand
like the
the the uh the causal relationship
between incident
incident rates and other types of
interventions and synthetic control is
one that gets you
used pretty often um so
um here what i'll do is i will uh
show this within the diagram so let's
say you
have a affected city san francisco right
so this is where you're
introducing your treatment effect your
synthetic
control is essentially you're taking
pre-treatment characteristics
of all of these different cities and
just doing a weighted
awaited average a weighted combination
um and essentially what it's doing is
that
this uh this weird combination of cities
is
is mirroring the treated or affected
city
prior to the um prior to the
intervention and so the constructed
control cities
are used to estimate what would have
happened to the affected cities
um if they were not you know if they
were not affected by the intervention
so the synthetic control is used to
create a counterfactual
which is essentially what all of these
methods are are trying to do
um and so uh once you have your
synthetic control
um it's a very straightforward method
you just compute the difference between
the treatment
treatment group and the synthetic
control in the post-treatment period
um and then you can get once again your
treatment effect
um i will leave it at here just because
um i think i just wanted to introduce a
synthetic control there are some
additional
assumptions that i think are very
important to this um computationally you
can use actually the
um synth package in r um
which is really good to be fully honest
like i was very privileged working at
uber we had like an
incredible experimentation platform that
was like created by an army of
engineers and data scientists where you
know if i was essentially looking at a
rare event
i had a set of different techniques that
i could just use all i had to do was
understand it and then it would be
automatically applied um
but these methods actually do take a
bunch of work and pre-analysis so
specifically here you want to understand
um what are those pre uh treatment
characteristics in order to be
in order to create um that weighted
combination
okay well um that is overall a wrap um
we went
over a lot in 20 minutes but these are
just some topics that are very
interesting and i think it's proof
that um you know you might only uh hear
from them
specifically in like policies um but
there's no reason that you can't apply
them in
other industries um i wanted to thank my
team um because i know that they're
listening right now but they also listen
to them
uh listen to this talk on thursday um so
very supportive of the team of data
science at codeacademy
um and finally i've linked additional
articles here about definitive
estimation synthetic control method
um some of my previous co-workers wrote
a causal inference
article um great one um and so i i just
i highly recommend if this is something
that you are interested
in um take a look and um i'll be around
later if you're if you're if you want to
chat
thank you thank you for that wonderful
talk
so folks we're here that's the end of
the talks
i don't know i don't i just flew right
by